welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the marvel cinematic universe
has finally begun to answer one critical
multiversal question for phase four why
do some variants across timelines and
universes look different played by
different actors like peter parker
across the spider-verse or loki further
and further away from the sacred
timeline while others look like
themselves played by the same actor like
doctor strange wanted maximoff and well
yeah i guess loki in the timeline where
he's president which one of us see you
well according to marvel producer richie
palmer the answer has less to do with
any one ironclad rule over the marvel
multiverse it's more centered on the
specific nature of these categories of
characters while characters like the
scarlet witch and doctor strange are
more constant fixed beings whose
universes revolve around them characters
like loki and peter parker are scrappier
more mischievous agents of chaos who
were always meant to have schrodinger's
diversity within their spectrums do
animals talk in this dimension because i
don't want to freak him out this is
especially fascinating to explore when
one looks back at the history of how
marvel had kevin feige secured the
rights to share peter parker in this
universe back in the spring of 2014 a
kind of nexus moment in our timeline in
which feige not only launched a new
incarnation of peter parker but
implicitly scored a stake in every peter
parker who preceded him all of them
webbed together in one sticky package
deal the fine print written in doctor
strange eldritch runes that only feige
could see
so in this episode of our mini series
feige's plan let's discuss why peter
parker is destined to be part of a
spider-verse family and how back in one
week in spring 2014 marvel studios
scored the biggest win ever yes
so after the re-release of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness on
streaming producer richie palmer spoke
to empire and explained why variant
doctor strange's and variant wanna
maximoffs are played by the same actor
while the loki's and the spider-man are
played by different actors palmer said
that he and the writer of loki
multiverse of madness michael waldron
discussed at length the story logic
behind this and that loki as an
inherently chaotic being would take a
variety of forms and that the closer to
the sacred timeline the more like tom
hiddleston loki looks for the further
away from 616 the more variants look
different he also said that when it
comes to peter parker the tradition of
alternate spider-man began in the early
2000s and that spider-man should cast a
wide net across the multiverse to have
peters who look different and totally
different people who are spider-man in
those alternate universes now the truth
of course is that there really is no
rule even with loki some variants are
played by different actors some are
doubled up by tom hiddleston himself the
primary factors that govern whether a
character's variant is played by
themselves or by someone else are really
the narrative needs of that particular
title and the commercial needs of the
studio which brings us to how peter
parker first landed in this mcu
hey everyone we all saw the news in late
2014 and 2015 the leaked sony emails
about the behind the scenes drama with
the spider-man franchise during the era
of mark webb and andrew garfield and the
surprise deal worked out between kevin
feige and amy pascal to share the
character in a new rebooted form exist
in the mcu leading to tom holland as
peter in captain america's civil war in
2016. however years later in fall 2021
it finally came out in a book from the
writers tara bennett and paul terry
called the story of marvel studios the
making of the marvel cinematic universe
which revealed that in the spring of
2014 two days before kevin feige had to
get together with amy pascal feige
secretly scrambled together an impromptu
mini retreat in a rented hotel suite in
santa monica an all hands on deck with
marvel core creative producers to
assemble a battle plan the goal to score
peter parker for the mcu at this secret
summit the marvel team agreed upon a few
things about their pitch for the
character first off they would not be
continuing andrew garfield's version of
the character despite andrew garfield
being a beloved star they wanted to
start fresh they wanted to keep peter
parker in high school so that he could
continue the day-to-day events of school
life like school trips and homework and
homecoming dances so pascal had invited
feige into a meeting in order to ask for
his advice for the next spider-man movie
because feige did at that point and
still does offer advice on marvel titles
produced at other studios but after this
secret meeting he then walked into this
meeting with amy pascal and instead of
just offering her some advice he went
into this pitch to completely co-produce
spider-man with sony pascal said that
she started crying and threw a sandwich
to kevin feige and threw him out of the
office the new york times even followed
up with feige and pascal about this
incident with spider-man no way home was
coming out last december and the two of
them confirmed that this did happen but
they laughed it off and they said there
was a second meeting at pascal's home
where feige pitched her specifically
what if tony stark makes peter's suit
and that image of a spider-man set in
the mcu's more modern technology world
just felt fresh to pascal so she said
yes and let's take a step back to
remember some history here 2014 was the
most important year for marvel studios i
respectfully disagree i guess like other
than 2008 when it all started what are
you talking about and you can make an
argument for 2018 black panther and
infinity war were pretty important for
them to get right uh what if this guy's
problem is starting but i still think
2014 was the nexus moment because
remember this was the year after their
shaky start to phase two 2014 saw the
releases of two of marvel's best films
to date captain america the winner
soldier which proved the russo brothers
and marcus mcfeely could shepherd this
franchise with darker themes those four
being the same team to produce civil war
infinity war and end game 2014 of course
also saw the release of guardians of the
galaxy which is even more surprising
because it proved lesser-known b players
could be just as successful in the mcu
with the right cocktail of casting music
and humor
[Laughter]
it's real two huge wins for marvel
studios and this same year sony's
spider-man franchise really ran out of
gas so 2014 was a nexus moment in which
marvel was able to secure its future
while sony needed a reset and by the end
of that year kevin feige bullishly
announced his entire phase 3 plan which
would culminate in a two-part infinity
war crossover event so by doing so he
made marvel studios inevitable
and so as this inevitable man with a
plan kevin feige was perfectly
positioned to take all the dlts thrown
at him and yet still be able to walk
back into the room with an offer no one
could refuse and really the smartest
aspect of this spider-man plan was to
recast peter parker as tom holland not
because tom holland was great in the
role and not because it replaced andrew
garfield in fans minds
but really because it left in the wings
for tom holland
two brothers for this new peter parker
to inevitably meet one day
thank you thank you thank you thank you
marvel studios knew that as much as we
loved tom holland in this role there
were always going to be fans still
attached to andrew garfield and toby
mcguire's versions of the characters the
true peter parker would always be a role
cohabitated by three different people a
need and a longing that we would always
have and pray for one day that marvel
studios would be able to pay off on and
they knew that that would always be
their plan so by bringing in a third
peter parker and delaying all of his
origins like we never heard with great
power until far later marvel studios set
up an organic rule of three's formula a
fan speculation so that any time we saw
spider-man and the number three together
in a sentence over several years we lost
our collective minds
here were three living working actors
all best known for playing spider-man a
character famous from the early 2000s as
a character destined to team up with
this variance in a universe now on the
cusp of multiversal incursions so really
this way it's better for peter parker to
exist in a multiverse where his variants
are played by other actors because it
provided to us a closure that we
instinctively craved since tom holland
took her for this role from andrew
garfield and said sandra garfield took
over the world from toby maguire they
created and imbalanced the order so that
they could restore the balance and of
course this is what fans who read the
spider-verse comics in the early 2000s
knew was possible so by detaching peter
parker from any one actor and by doing
the same with loki this gives marvel
studios a path to recast any of their
names by virtue of their chaotic nature
or their proclivity for bridge building
therefore individuals like captain
america tony stark reed richards
t'challa there is now a multiverse of
variants out there with different faces
who thanks to how marvel studios
introduced the loki's and the peters now
have a path forward that fans will be
okay with thanks for watching this
episode of fighties plan follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
rockstar subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you